[Musique]
un chiffre suffit à illustrer le
problème à celui de la balance
commerciale qui atteint un déficit
abyssal de 174 milliards nous sommes les
derniers les derniers après l'Espagne la
Roumanie et la Grèce l'ensemble de nos
industries sont partis à l'extérieur
nous perdons tous les marchés c'est le
fruit d'une politique de
désindustrialisation depuis 20 ans les
services la balance commerciale est
positive aujourd'hui de 50 milliards
mais il sera facile de les télémigrer de
d'être à Singapour de pouvoir assurer
les services notre délégation aux
entreprises formules 10 propositions
parmi ces 10 propositions il y a bien
entendu la loi d'orientation économique
elle devra définir des objectifs en
matière de commerce extérieur mais aussi
avoir pour axe important notre
souveraineté économique afin
d'identifier les secteurs les
compétences les entreprises à soutenir
enfin spécialités que l'on doit
développer ensuite nous avons toute une
série de propositions opérationnelles
pour soutenir les TPE et PME les ETI
dans cette stratégie nous avons environ
5% 4% d'entreprises de taille
intermédiaires mais qui représente 35 %
des exportations donc il faut développer
ces entreprises permettent au PME de se
développer et pour faire cela faciliter
la transmission des entreprises pour
qu'elle puisse ensuite grossir une
véritable vision stratégique pour notre
économie et pour notre commerce
extérieur
[Musique]